so i think we got time for one more
question and
this one i think makes sense for both of
us to chime in on so uh the question is
from greg's medicine cabinet
uh that's that's the name they provided
at various points you guys have talked
about creatine magnesium and snorting
algae
memes and nightshades aside and has a
comment here that
i guess ashwagandha is a himalayan yak
shaving forum meme
i have no idea what any of those words
mean but i i know what they all mean
individually but when you put them
together it loses
all concept for me yeah apparently
ashwagandha is both a meme and a
nightshade
according to this user the the nature of
the question is which supplements don't
suck
so i'm going to start with the
non-controversial ones and we'll let the
conversation evolve from there so
creatine is awesome
if you want to be strong if you want to
be muscular creatine is pretty great
there was a recent meta-analysis that we
covered in mass about
creatine and fat loss indicating that it
might help with fat loss
i i'm pretty unconvinced uh
by the data suggesting that creatine
might
meaningfully boost fat loss maybe
there's just the slightest
just razor thin effect and that's okay
like we'll take it
but you don't take creatine for the fat
loss you take creatine for the power the
strength the muscle gains
uh interesting stuff coming out about
creatine potentially
favorably affecting bone and the brain i
think
uh a lot of people aren't aware how
important creatine is for the brain
like i mean if you have a a genetic
defect as it pertains to brain creatine
levels it's catastrophic
oh and if you're a vegetarian or vegan i
know we've touched on this before in a
prior episode but
that was probably three or four months
ago if you're a vegetarian
or vegan like i would recommend creatine
to just about anyone but i would
a million times more recommend creatine
to vegetarians or vegans
um like virtually all of the dietary
creatine you're gonna get in
is going to come from meat consumption
and so if you don't have meat in your
diet
you're not going to be ingesting
virtually any creatine in day to day
life
and so in the studies that look at
performance
in omnivores versus vegans vegetarians
with and without creatine
supplementation
the boosts in performance are larger for
vegetarians and vegans
and in studies that look at like mental
performance
you give creatine to
young healthy omnivores it generally
doesn't affect mental performance it may
in the elderly but that's
that's another topic um but
in like young otherwise healthy
vegetarians and vegans
creatine supplementation seems to
improve mental performance and mood as
well
so yeah i mean creatine is great for
everyone but especially if you're a
vegetarian or vegan
find yourself a good vegetarian or vegan
creatine supplement and use it
it's going to be doubly beneficial for
you
yeah definitely the other one that's
pretty non-controversial is protein
you don't need to supplement with
protein but you definitely want to make
sure you have plenty in your diet
whether that's coming from food or from
supplements and when it comes to the
the protein supplements as we've talked
about there are many many many options
and all seem to do a pretty good job as
long as you're dosing them
effectively to me those are the kind of
two top tier supplements that no one's
really going to fight you on too much
but now we get into the second tier
specifically as it pertains to form
performance my second tier supplements
for performance purposes are caffeine
beta alanine citrulline malate
and sodium bicarbonate uh the reason
their second tier is because
their res their uh
their effects on performance are not
quite as consistent in the literature
and not quite as
large when it when you compare them to
something like creatine
there are plenty of studies indicating
benefits for each of those four
supplements they each have some
downsides or at least some
some uh types of exercise where they
don't do a lot
uh but generally speaking if you're
taking one of those four
for performance reasons you you could at
least substantiate that claim with some
really solid evidence so
caffeine especially for endurance
performance is pretty reliable
caffeine's pretty solid but there's
plenty of evidence suggesting
it facilitates lifting performance as
well uh citrulline malate it's a mixed
bag
it's it the first few studies looked
very promising
the last few that have come out have
looked less promising and so now i think
the citrulline malate research is really
at a crossroads
are we going to start replicating a lot
of those early findings or are we going
to find that
the research starts turning the other
way but in any case right now the
totality of the evidence would indicate
that there is a
small positive effect particularly when
it comes to things like
repetitions to fatigue you know strength
endurance type outcomes
now beta alanine and sodium bicarbonate
those are
more applicable to performance that
involves
a high degree of acidosis so things that
are really pushing your anaerobic energy
systems
the kind of classic way to think about
it is if you're doing a 400 800
1200 meter sprint those are like right
in the sweet spot for
any time you're you're generating all of
that lactate all of that
all those protons trying to buffer some
of that acidity that's where these
supplements really shine
if you're a power lifter and you're
doing sets of three
you're probably not going to get a huge
benefit from these two especially if you
have ample rest between sets
but but still there are some certain uh
types of programs where they might have
a place
now uh outside of that there's really
nothing i recommend for performance
outside of extremely
unique circumstances okay but there are
a few other supplements that i i have
bought in the past and do use from time
to time
uh the three that come to mind for me
are ashwagandha
tyrosine and theanine aren't you
forgetting one
trend balloon ah yes yes that's we don't
talk about that on the air
and copious amounts of marijuana that i
i pretend
to to hate just to keep people off of
the trail you know keep people off my
scent
uh but yeah so uh ashwagandha there
there are
some trials they're they're not like the
most rigorous highest quality trials
you've ever seen but there are some
lab-based trials indicating that
ashwagandha supplement can be
somewhat helpful when it comes to
anxiety um and it is an adaptogen so i
think there's
uh studies looking at physical exertion
as well right
i don't know well you take it as well no
i i do
um i don't
have anxiety issues i'm pretty [ __ ]
chill
but at all that is completely true
uh but i feel even chiller
when i take ashwagandha and so
man i'm just in it to vibe yeah i think
there are some studies
uh not a large enough body of evidence
that i'd call it conclusive but i think
there are some studies looking at
uh responses to physical stressors as
well as psychological that that
indicates some positive effects
slight changes in cortisol and
testosterone levels
nothing to really write home about but
the ashwagandha um
there's enough there especially when it
comes to some of the more
psychologically oriented outcomes to say
like okay this is enough evidence to at
least
at least acknowledge it you know not not
conclusive but
uh and the other thing i always put a
caveat there anything in the realm of
of uh mental health or anything like
that always defer to a healthcare
practitioner if you think you have any
kind of depressive or anxiety related
symptoms
you see a physician about it right away
you don't say i wonder if there's an
herb i can lean on
you got to get you got to get
professional help for that
tyrosine and theanine tend to pair very
well with caffeine greg and i are both
just absolutely gripped by our caffeine
addictions
um no way out of it no light at the end
of that tunnel we are
completely hooked but the cool thing
is uh tyrosine a lot of times can
potentiate the effects uh
some of the uh stimulatory effects of
caffeine and theanine
uh how would you describe what theanine
does with caffeine
helps take the edge off yeah i mean it
there's some evidence that theanine
alone people have promoted as something
to
generally chill you out a little bit and
i know i've talked to some people that
when they take
thee and they're like i hate it because
it makes me sleepy um i
i think it's kind of easy to conflate
like the general like
the way it takes the edge off and just
kind of takes you down a level
in in terms of like your your amplitude
you know what i mean i think a lot of
people they feel that and they're like
i'm tired
but but for me i think theanine is is a
really nice especially if you're taking
a big dose of caffeine
you can get the enhanced alertness of
caffeine
without feeling like you're jittery and
uncomfortably amped up
and so tyrosine and theanine tend to
pair quite well
with caffeine not a lot of
not a ton of lab based research on that
stuff but um
but but they do tend to pair fairly well
now you you put a couple on the list
here
well i i was actually wondering if you
would like to mention
the next one yeah so so it's
it's more in your wheelhouse i would say
correct yeah so betaine
uh betaine is found in beets that's
where it gets its name but it's also
found
in spinach and some seafood and some
whole grains and stuff like that so
b-t betaine is commonly found in the
food supply in various types of foods
and it had there have been some trials
on using it as a supplement
and those human trials are really based
off
it seems they're based off betaine's use
uh in the livestock industry um
for for years especially in in pigs i
believe they've used it as
a food additive in the the food of
livestock to increase
uh their muscularity and also to reduce
their their
excess adiposity and so if you go all
the way back to i mean one of our first
episodes we had
dr jason kaliva on to talk about his
betaine research
and there's not a lot of it there's not
a lot of super relevant data with
betaine
but it does find its way into a lot of
pre-workout formulas
and there is some human evidence if
you're a mass subscriber
coming up december 1st in the december
issue
i reviewed a brand new meta-analysis
about betaine and its effects on fat
loss and it does look like
in resistance-trained people that are
training on a pretty sensible resistance
training program
uh there might be some modest but
measurable
fat loss benefits the effects on
performance and lean mass are not
quite as impressive but it might be a
somewhat helpful fat loss aid
definitely need more data we're going
off very few studies on that but
uh but there's something to it okay so
the
the only three that i would add to that
list for
more like niche uses well i guess one
isn't an issue
it probably applies to about 25
of humans on the planet but uh
so one of them is taurine
so taurine people believe a lot of
weird [ __ ] about taurine like if if i
had a nickel for every time
someone told me that taurine was
extracted from bull semen
i'd probably have like buck 50 give or
take
like that's that's a reasonably common
thing uh
it's not the the reason it's called
taurine is because it was like first
isolated from
cal's stomachs but uh has nothing to do
with bull semen
but um the reason i'd put taurine on
there
is if you are a bit of a partier
or if you smoke or if you just generally
have
a lifestyle that is um
generally bad ass i was going to say
generally unconducive to health
but bad ass yeah that works um
i don't know that there's good human
evidence for this yet but there is
a very plausible mechanism and pretty
decent rodent evidence
so taurine is one of the primary
antioxidants in your brain
and it is the primary antioxidant in
your testes if you're a male and so
if you drink a lot or if you smoke
cigarettes
or just you know generally live a pretty
rough and tumble
inflammation promoting lifestyle that
can
both decrease brain function and also
decrease
testosterone production and so again in
rodent models
supplementing with taurine while also
drinking a lot
or i don't know how they
do cigarette studies and mice but they
do somehow
i assume they don't roll up tiny little
cigarettes for them but whatever i think
they do
i'd like to imagine they do that'd be
cool yeah uh
anyway so when studies like that in mice
it seems to help preserve just general
brain function
and testicular function so
i don't drink nearly as much as i used
to
but i did notice that like back when i
did drink a little bit more
when i supplemented with taurine i did
just generally feel
more vigor so i don't know maybe there
was something to that
um and man
so th this was this was a question
highlighted in blue
so i thought trex was taking it i didn't
do pre-podcast reading i'm going to
throw something out there that i think
is true
if it turns out to be wrong don't
crucify me for it
i want to say that there is also some
evidence showing that
in middle aged males who
don't live that hard drinking smoking
lifestyle
it can also increase testosterone levels
a little bit
so that's not super relevant to me but
yeah just in general
if you drink if you smoke may not be a
bad idea to take
taurine for half the population for your
testes and for everyone for your brain
and potentially liver as well the next
one i had on here
was rhodiola rosea so rhodiola
is an adaptogen much like ashwagandha
its benefits seem to be more related to
uh like vigor promoting and anti-fatigue
type stuff more so than being anxiolytic
and so there is
both pretty good animal and human
research
on rhodiola helping to mitigate
mental stress and mental fatigue so
there's
there is some performance literature on
rhodiola now
um it's a bit of a mixed bag i'm not
super sold on it
but as far as mental performance goes
if you are in a good mental state
like if you're well rested and not
stressed out it's probably not going to
do that much for you
but if you're sleep deprived if you're
under a lot of stress
or if you're like trying to do something
like deal with caffeine withdrawals or
something like that if you're
a crazy person who doesn't want to use
caffeine for some reason
um rhodiola seems to improve both
like mood perceptions of of
energy and vigor and objectively
measured mental performance
in situations where you are dealing with
sleep deprivation or high stress
so that is one that i would recommend
for
for situations like that not as good as
a night of sleep but
if you can't get a night of sleep
rhodiola is probably going to help a
little bit
um and then the one that i said is
probably relevant for
about a quarter of the global population
is
vitex agnes castus or vitex fruit
so this one's for the ladies
vitex is super interesting
and it honestly shocks me that i don't
see more people talking about it and
more people taking it
um so it has a couple mechanisms of
action but one of the things it it does
is it's a e2 receptor modulator
i'm pretty sure but in terms of its
actual effects
if you deal with really bad
pre-menstrual or menstrual symptoms or
you deal with
migraines associated with the menstrual
cycle
uh vitex seems to help considerably
with that um so like decreasing severity
of symptoms by like 30
40 percent if you take it daily for i
think at least two months
can reduce incidence of migraines
associated with
premenstrual and menstrual symptoms
again by about 40 50
um not a huge huge body of literature on
it but i want to say there's
three or four studies now and they've
all found pretty similar results
in terms of its ability to alleviate
premenstrual and menstrual symptoms so
anyway um that is something
that if that is something you deal with
certainly a supplement worth looking
into